Thanks Lauren. First let's look at delusions. Delusions are often bizarre and
grandiose and they are part of a patently false belief system that is
maintained in spite of its irrationality, for example a person may believe he
is Jesus Christ and moreover these appear to be very real to that person, so
that person would actually believe that he was in fact Jesus Christ. We also
have hallucinations and these are convincing sensory experieneces that occur in
the absence of an external stimulus. Auditory hallucinations are the most
common and involve hearing voices inside their head often telling them negative
things about themselves or even sometimes telling the person to injure another
individual. However, some people with schizophrenia have reported that there
are sometimes more positive voices in their heads, in terms of intentions. We
can also have a visual hallucinations. This involves seeing things that aren't
really there. There can be tactile hallucinations. And this involves feeling
something that isn't there. And finally, we can even have olfactory
hallucinations, which is smelling something that isn't there, either. Delusions
and hallucinations are considered positive symptoms because they are not
present in people in general.